c'est un drame dont on a beaucoup parlé
ce week end celui du décès de la jeune
vanille
âgé de seulement un an qui a été enlevée
et tuée par sa propre mère c'est samedi
soir que les autorités ont décidé de
lancer l' alerte enlèvement concernant
la disparition inquiétante du nouveau-né
par sa maman une femme de 39 ans hébergé
depuis un an dans le centre maternel
danger un foyer pour femmes enceintes et
mères isolées en raison des troubles
psychiatriques dont elle souffre
l'enfant confié à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance depuis sa naissance était en
visite auprès de sa mère au moment de sa
disparition c'est dans un hôtel de
nantes que la maman a été interpellé
grâce au signalement diffusé par la
lerte enlèvement elle a ensuite été
placé en garde à vue pour soustraction
de mineur par ascendant
c'est durant cet interrogatoire qu'elle
a avoué avoir tué son enfant et a révélé
l'endroit où elle avait caché le corps à
ange et d'où elle est originaire un
drame terrible qui s'est déroulée
vendredi soir bien avant le lancement de
l' alerte enlèvement sur internet de
nombreuses personnes se sont montrées
bouleversé par ce terrible fait divers
et certains ont dénoncé le laxisme de la
part des institutions qui aurait selon
eux coûté la vie à sept enfants alors
selon vous le drame aurait-il pu être
évité
alors que sait-on de la maman de vanille
le profil psychologique de nathalie
stefan 39 ans est particulièrement
complexe est présente des troubles
psychiatriques importants
elle est hébergée depuis un an dans un
foyer pour femmes enceintes et mères
isolées sur facebook à se présente comme
une ancienne assistante maternelle liés
si vous êtes avec nous aujourd'hui vous
avez vous êtes auteur du livre dans
l'enfer des foyers membres du conseil
national de la protection de l'enfance
je vous dis si on a voulu avoir aussi le
témoignage de liesse ce soir c'est que
tout le monde en a parlé bien sûr ce
week-end et tous les enfants tous les
pères de familles toutes les mères de
famille ont pensé à à cette histoire
liège vous vous avez vécu un cauchemar
dans une famille d'accueil
j'avais subi deux années de sévices de
privation de nourriture en trop tôt si
oui et aujourd'hui vous êtes avec nous
soit parce que vous dites que pour vous
le drame concernant vanier aurait pu
être évité je pense qu'il est trop tôt
pour tirer des conclusions de cette
affaire par contre il ya des questions
qui doivent être posées une raison
fondamentale qui s'est passé dans cette
situation très particulière c'est que la
mère de vanille était quand même
atteintes de pathologies psychiatriques
lourdes
vous l'avez rappelé est ce que je ne
comprends pas puisque ma mère était dans
le même état
c'est pourquoi les visites et les droits
qui lui ont été accordés ont été aussi
souple il ya d'autres solutions qui
aurait pu être
possibles notamment des visites
médiatisées médiatisée c'est en présence
de professionnels de travailleurs
sociaux des psychologues
là ça n'a pas été le cas cette mère a
deux enfants cette mère a été elle même
une ancienne enfant placé à la deux
enfants il ya eu des craintes qui ont
déjà été mises sur la table à plusieurs
reprises notamment au retour de visite
et moi c'était dysfonctionnements là qui
me kim qui m'inquiète pour l'avenir de
tous les autres enfants placés et qui
m'énerve parce que ce n'est pas la
première fois qu on dit en france qu'il
ne faut pas faire passer les liens du
sang avant les intérêts des enfants mais
enfin c'est des générations entières
qu'on est en train de sacrifier et ça
les pouvoirs publics et doivent s'en
rendre compte quand on laisse l'autorité
parentale à un parent qui n'a même pas
les capacités déjà de s'occuper de lui
même
c'est extrêmement questionnant et c'est
préoccupant pour la vie de ses enfants
jean michel oui je comprends très bien
ce qui est ce qu'il nous dise si c'est
vrai que tu étais déjà vous en parlait
ici c'était très émouvant mais
malheureusement je crois que c'est
toujours facile de le dire après met sur
le compte pas si on savait le nombre de
gens qui souffrent de troubles
psychologiques sont liberté en france on
peut pas arrêter tout le monde
on est quelque part c'est malheureux
obligé de faire confiance à peu la
fatalité c'est terrible mais voilà on
peut pas arrêter tous les gens qui sont
capables de faire des choses
or il y en a partout sur la terre à tous
les genres et vers la lors une mère sait
quand il faut truc tu te plantes ce soir
à 18 heures il ya le procureur de la
république qui est également revenu sur
le fait que la mère a déjà oublié de
ramener un enfant à son foyer et il
explique cormier sont remis ça rien
avaient tous souligné sur son profil
psychologique à 18h tout à l'heure le
procureur est revenue sur le fait que
tout était prémédité
jeudi c'est ça qui est là pour lui nadal
l'a répété il n'y avait aucun signe qui
pouvait soupçonner la mère d'un tel
fonds va revoir ce qu'a dit procurant
regarder à 18 heures le mobile du
passage à l'acte
ils semblent être liées à son départ du
centre maternel jour à partir duquel
elle a décidé par divers moyens auxquels
elle a successivement penser d'eux
donner la mort à son enfant aucun signe
ne nous permettait de penser que ce
passage à l'acte était envisagée par là
par la maman au contraire les éducateurs
décrivent une évolution positive d'une
maman qui s'investissent et de plus en
plus dans le lien c'était aussi un des
enjeux de la de la mesure éducative
alors c'est comme que voilà il aurait dû
éloigner le au maximum la mère de sa
fille moi je suis pas en train de dire
que tous les parents qui sont atteints
de pathologies psychiques peuvent pas
être parent d'un des parents qui sont
qui ont des maladies mentales et qui
sont tout à fait capables d'occuper une
place auprès de leurs enfants cette
femme à la pas été accompagnée
correctement voilà ce que je suis en
train de dire ce soir c'est que
normalement on aurait dû prendre des
précautions suffisantes quand on a des
antécédents comme ce qu'elle avait c'est
tout c'est ya rien de plus compliqué et
et qu'on en soit encore dans ces débats
là aujourd'hui pour se dire est ce que
oui ou non elle est capable ou pas
capable le problème n'est pas là on a
une personne qui est malade elle doit
être accompagnée sur le plan
psychiatrique
on pourrait en parler de la psychiatrie
en france qui est dans un état c'est ça
complètement ravagée et puis cette
gamine elle aurait jamais dû être
laissés seuls avec gilles alors il ya
deux choses d'abord ce qui a fait
polémique c'est le moment de
déclenchement du dispositif alerte
enlèvement on a dit ce qu'on l'a
déclenchée trop tard or il semble sur
escaut on va on va rappeler il a été
enclenchée donc décroché pour la 24e
fois depuis sa création de mes 6 et aux
alentours de 23h pour signalé
l'enlèvement de sa fille de vanille et
c'est vrai que les gens ont dit que
c'était un petit peu parce que c'était
possible de longs crochets avant non il
semble hélas que le passage à l'acte de
la mer soit très rapide
après l'enlèvement donc le dispositif
alerte n'aurait pas pu solutionner pour
répondre à liesse elle avait la mer un
droit ponctuelles terre que c'était
encadré elle ne pouvait pas voir son
enfant dès qu'elle le souhaitait c'était
très encadré
déjà elle l'avait ramené plus tard que
prévu mais le procureur l'a dit sur les
premières investigations à rien ne
permettait de penser que la mère pouvait
passer à l'acte pour donc dont il n'y
avait aucun signe tangible
donc de mon point de vue
je vous comprends tout à fait mais vous
allez un peu vite parce qu'il ya eu
aucune alerte y avait pas de signe alors
je suis le premier à dénoncer les
institutions mais là je règne chez lui à
ces annonces et les institutions et
c'est pas mon rôle ici ce soir
la notion de danger elle est établie
parce qu'il ya un placement voilà cette
gamine elle a été placée parce que la
notion de danger a été reconnu par un
juge des enfants sinon elle n'aurait pas
été placé sept enfants donc à partir du
moment où la place et qu'on considère
qu'elle est en danger avec sa mère soit
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on doit retirer
les droits parentaux à cette femme parce
qu'il y a un travail qui peut être est
possible en l'occurrence ce travail il
est possible quand il ya suffisamment de
personnes autour de la situation pour
pouvoir épauler soutenir et était lié
cet accompagnement ça n'a pas été le cas
la mère a une autorisation de sortie de
droit d'hébergement et de droit de
visite de 48 heures où elle peut faire
littéralement ce qu'elle veut avec son
enfant
le résultat est là elle est morte voilà
alors c'est vrai que c'est ça nous a
tous vraiment je vous dis ravagé et
cette situation aurait pu arriver à
d'autres on s'intéressé c'est le cas
c'est déjà l'heure je veux dire enfin
encore une fois je fais le parallèle
avec ma propre histoire etc qui est
différente mais j'ai une mère qui est
malade mental moi si on m'avait laissé
avec elle
seul sans surveillance il ya de fortes
chances pour que je sois jeté dans la
seine
enfin littéralement message est très
important voulait absolument que vous
veniez soir y est parce qu'il faut pas
que ça recommence sa pause de sa bosse
pas mal d'autres questions parce qu'en
fait on peut pas que stimuler cette
situation elle est désastreuse mais est
fausse mais traduit une réalité de
terrain qui est bien complexe
on parle beaucoup des hôpitaux et de la
crise que traversent les hôpitaux a
juste à juste raison d'ailleurs de le
faire mais les services d'aidé sociale à
l'enfance quand un travailleur social
doit accompagner 50 enfants 60 enfants
ça par personne est ce qu'il est capable
de faire des évaluations correct est-ce
qu'il a le temps d'investiguer
suffisamment mais évidemment que non
quand on a 60 gamins à gérer c'est pas
possible on va voir ce qu'on pensait les
téléspectateurs puisque c'est vrai c'est
vraiment un drame louis à 78% voyez
elias on voulait absolument que soyez
avec nous soit pour pousser voilà ce cri
d' allah et c'est question qu'on doit se
poser pour ne plus que ça arrive merci
[Applaudissements]